One of the main things
professional prototypers and
UX engineers do is build
out prototypes in code.
Often, we use things like Framer.js,
Sublime Text, Android Studio, or Xcode.
With these tools, we can make
prototypes of arbitrary fidelity.
This is really useful when you have a
particular feature that needs to be seen
to be understood.
Often, users will have trouble
understanding such a feature
from a low or medium fidelity prototype
since it doesn't always come
through in those mediums.
By building out a minimum viable version
of that feature, we can test whether it
makes sense to build a production
quality version later on.
Another use case that makes
code prototypes vital
is dealing realistically
with user input.
We use this when making prototypes for
Google Maps, we want to understand how
the changes impact a user's ability to
find the information
they're looking for.
Building a prototype that
leverages real data and
user input can provide valuable insight
into how a user approaches the app.
Remember, that Jeremy wanted
to type his information
when presented with our
inVision prototype.